Max f c the trophy check me out on ble C
podcast trophy
gang yo man ble C podcast special guest
in here somebody call him uh the hottest
rapper in LA right now the trophy for
sure definitely uh you got to explain
the trophy I saw you explain it
essentially like it's like you're doing
big [__] X Force here like you like yeah
you like a you like a joint cuz you like
a trophy cuz like a big dog big dog
status cuz you like a [__] did you see
academics uh when he got into a fight
with this girl he was like yelling like
I'm the prize no I a see I you he was
like I'm the prize he was yelling at his
girl you know what I'm saying we should
say I'm the trophy to your [__] you
know what I'm saying like they you won
you're lucky they be already knowing
some of them they be already knowing who
the trophy is they you already know what
is your are you like juggling multiples
right now or like how how's the how I
mean obviously things are going very
well for you right now so I'm assuming
that the attention I mean you probably
always been doing well in the ladies
department I gather oh yeah hell yeah
always had [__] G like a young [__]
and I always had like long hairz growing
up so the [__] used to long hair they
want to braid your hair they used think
I was a little girl growing up like look
at the little girl they like my son is
my son's mixed then he has really long
hair yeah so anytime we go to a
restaurant they're always like what does
she want I'm
like they cut my [__] too when I was
growing up my sh would have been way
longer I grew it out when I went to
prison oh [__] they cut my sh I was like
11 10 what is it about girl like girls
like guys with long hair is it cuz they
they like to braid it they like to like
what is it know cuz I don't know
probably that they like to braid
probably I don't know
I don't know that's what's up man so but
certain [__] like I don't know
certain [__] like different [__]
though go certain [__] like waves
certain [__] like dreads true it's
like different [__] depends on the [__]
why' you never dread your hair hey it's
funny cuz I I started my [__] I started
dreads in prison but I a had no patience
cuz for the [__] to lock so I'm
like let me take these [__] out
braids I feel like you get a little more
flexibility you want to take them out
you do more you do more [__] Rock the
afro ponytail braids mhm pop some o
braids you can do whatever you want to
do you [__] around and do look like a
whole different person in two weeks you
come out here with an afro no G that's
how Snoop used to be in the '90s you
would see Snoop with all his braids and
then you would just think that's how
Snoop looks and then you would see him
with the [__] like oh
[__] um so are the are the ladies like
elevating in terms of the quality
nowadays yeah hell yeah on the dead
homies cuz [__] talking about they
got all type of nurse jobs doctor jobs
do all type of sh business doctors
getting at you hell yeah all type of
[__] cuz they homies that got [__]
rolling I say for you the little bunk
[__] though still trying though here
and there you know the little bunk
[__] still trying to shoot their
little shot on the dead be little Buck
[__] still try you know they going to
always try cold shoulder I mean they're
they have a purpose right just like some
head in the back seat somewhere or
something n hell no cuz cuz cuz once you
start doing [__] like that on a day
homet you going you going to get used to
doing [__] like that like all right only
doctors are sucking your dick right now
yeah that type of [__] models model spy
little [__] cuz I no little bunk
[__] cuz you going to do it one time
and then you going get comfortable with
doing it cuz you going to do it again
again again are you comfortable with um
hooking up with the girls with the only
fans going
on I wouldn't make a [__] with only
fans like my main [__] but she could be
like some fun like for like yeah for
like on some fun type [__] like on her
like caught up in a moment one of those
moments probably on the day homies but I
never no you can't be my she so fine and
she came to she was like that [__] don't
mean nothing I want to be your main
[__] I'll delete my only fans right now
I'll delete it off the interet it
depends on what type of content she had
on there cuz some [__] got only fans
and they only showing like feed some
[__] got only fans they just doing like
other [__] if she like on there [__]
and sucking and she's not [__] and
suck and she's just on there [__]
herself with the dildo nah on a dead
homie that's not spoy cuz too she's not
with any other people still too many
people seen that though what if what if
she's only on H so as long as so if the
pussy's being shown you're out yeah
that's that's that's so I was going to
say what if she's just on there getting
her [__] ate by a
girl some girl on girl [__] and maybe
you're like yo she's like I want to go
back to the straight [__] no that's
still that's still not spoy cuz cuz it's
still like on a dead home I don't know
that's still not that's not a good look
I respect he listen I if she just on
there like you know
iine with your standards I align with
your standards I'm married as well but
you know I yeah that's not straight I
don't want my [__] on the internet
getting her [__] at by no not your main
one yeah not my main [__] yeah you have
uh do you have a son or a daughter I got
a son his name trophy his name's trophy
yeah [__] great name for a kid I'm
gang you 5 months 5 months old shout out
to Trophy what is has fatherhood changed
you at
all
uh yeah in what way yeah because like I
got to get back home to my son so
instead of like doing stupid [__] not
thinking I got to like you know I'm
living for him now so everything I do is
got to re be like for him type [__]
instead of just moving sloppy in the
streets I got to like think about him
like I got to raise my son yeah like the
goal should always be to get back home
to your kid right yeah for sure are you
like instead of like you just kidless
and you just out here just doing
whatever like 100% And and they don't
got [__] to lose exactly are you
changing shitty diapers yeah I did a
couple times but I let his mom really
deal with that [__] mom's dealing with
the [__] yeah I know his mom deal with
that [__] I had my kid when he was a
baby shat on me on accident he was like
had diarrhea and he didn't pissed on me
a couple times threw up on me all the
time yeah the puke is gonna happen the
baby the baby milk puke yeah I'd have
been H and really put that [__] on he
didn't threw up right on and there I'm
like [__] take it off yeah it's crazy
how's your how's are you and uh his mom
have a like a healthy relationship n
hell no man that [__] toxic as a
[__] bro [__] sh what's her
ethnicity black she's black okay yeah I
got a Mexican baby mama who's a
psychopath yeah to her yeah she crazy as
a [__] toxic how though like
obviously like crazy cuz she want you
she do crazy [__] like she just know my
trigger points cuz so I be out whatever
on the day homie she just like trigger a
[__] bro for have me like off my Square
cuz homies now now was like now I'm
being like way better can she send you a
text and ruin your mood on the dead that
type of [__] cuz she used to do that
type of [__] she do that [__] she'll
know you're out doing some [__] and then
she'll be like I'm ruin his [__]
night and then sh you some [__] yeah or
post some stupid [__] on the dead homies
that me and her only know about like on
the dead homies posting little stupid
[__] on [__] like just dumb [__] but
yeah [__] like that though that [__] be
happen a lot send me D what would be
like a something you I mean you don't
have to share but something that you
could share was like a trigger of yours
where she would just [__] like put
the knife in uh when she call me a dead
beat oh that's not dead homies I hate
that [__] I'll be doing it up for my son
cuz yeah and it's like you also are are
obviously you have a career that's
flourishing right now but N I made her I
made her uh make a promise cuz to never
do that [__] again guess what she ain't
been doing a lady cuz you already know I
do it up I do whatever for him so yeah
you're supporting your kid right yeah
that just yeah yeah that just one of
them though calling me a dead but she
got she a lot of low trigger points like
I said I've been getting better at her
now though I'll just be ignoring her now
cuz she been getting better at like what
she she work or does she just take care
of the kid and you you yeah she work
okay yeah well [__] man then like you
know her mom help us like watch you
can't call somebody a dead beat bro yeah
especially if they ain't a dead
especially if they not one that [__]
just like I get it if they're a dead
beat I get it but like it's it's it's
cuz she she sees what's happening she
wants to like you know yeah yeah yeah
she want you to herself bro that too but
like she know she had it but she like
blew it it so she blew it so you guys
are not dating anymore you guys are just
no you know parenting co-parenting hey
co-parenting is important especially
like listen when your kid starts to get
older she got to kill all that toxic
[__] cuz the kid she straight though she
she straight on gang that's good she did
a lot for me that's what's up man um for
you like obviously you've had a pretty
interesting 12 months but really the
last 6 seven months things have really
picked up for you like
um are you feeling that now are you kind
of feeling like okay because I've heard
you have a reputation that you're crazy
I don't know if you know that about
yourself that's what they say lot a
couple of people homie's crazy he's
really like he really crazy you what
crazy I I heard that um but I'm
wondering like for you obviously five
months ago you have a kid your rap
career is flourishing like crazy are you
feeling like oh [__] like I really got
some like lifechanging momentum that
could go you know we've I mean you've
seen a lot of people get hot and go away
get hot die you know what I'm saying
like um are you kind of like feeling
like finally like oh [__] you know what
this is for real like this this rap
shit's really working out for me yeah
hell yeah lately I've been feeling like
that like I've been feeling like a real
artist L the attention I've been getting
the type of people that been tapping in
now like hell yeah this [__] like
different who tapped in with you that
you were like oh [__] like this is crazy
that was like oh uh estg estg who walk
who was sitting in this chair and stood
up and walked off yeah yeah he stood up
and got he didn't like the fact that I
was proba he said buk what you say bro I
asked him what he thought about aliens
yeah and then I asked him about his
football career and he [__] stood up
and walked off football career right he
was no he played football he went to the
NFL combine he was like a linebacker at
I think Eastern Kentucky he was like a
like he could have went to the league
yeah he probably I don't think he W I
don't I don't know I just thought the
football thing was like a there's video
of him like [__] in press conferences
like [__] people up on the football
field so I was just asking him about it
and he was like what's that got to do do
with my music and I was like but it's
got a lot it's you br I'm asking about
you dog like you know what I'm saying
like yeah D yeah he probably yeah he
wanted to talk about so estg tapped in
yeah he's dope I love his music yeah he
wants to work yeah he told me to send
him something oh that' be hard yeah that
[__] crazy any of the like West Coast LA
ogs hit you at
all
uh no I not know West Coast or G matter
of fact on the de homie somebody uh on
[__] cut one of my old man did tell me
one of this one of them old [__] he
got a know name too cuz I forget right
now cuz I be smoking weed and [__] on
Old like yeah one back from one of them
corrup like type
eras one of them [__] he said they
want to work me but I'm like I'm sporty
all that [__] A is before your era yeah
I respect it though on the D homies I
respect OG's on like if Snoop hits you
Snoop you know that's different you know
that's that's Sno that's on the D but a
lot of that [__] I'm just like know
don't be feeling ain't my error but I
respect OG's though um for people who
aren't from La obviously you have
rolling 40s 4 tattooed on your on your
lip people who can't read it um I think
that the most famous CP from La in the
last decade is probably nip who is you
know obviously is affiliated with the
roling 60s yeah um are you guys like
very what's the difference between the
rolling 40s rolling 60s and well it's
kind of like [__] it's kind of like the
same thing like the 40s well in LA and
the hoods like that's going to be like
the closest hoods going to get to like d
and near being the same it's like only a
couple shits off from us being different
like we like anything that's got like
rolling in front of it it's kind of like
you n cuz it's like rolling 30s rolling
hundreds all type of [__] but just the
40s and the 60s cuz we just like we just
like it just been always you guys kind
of move in the same direction type [__]
on gang so we just like all act Al like
40s and the 60s on game same Ops same
Ops that makes sense okay um was nip
somebody who you grew up like you know
looking up to not necessarily looking up
to cuz but I had like a on a de homies a
couple uh nip songs I used to play on
gang ain't going to lie I play I I
listen to C more after FP but I think
the world was like that I mean I mean
I've known nip since 09 he was on my
show in 09 but like you know
unfortunately he passed away and then
people really gave him flowers he
deserved after die it made me like look
at certain [__] different and pay
attention to her lyrics a little bit
more on gang but like y'all had a couple
songs like that that was hot though that
I used to play while he was
alive I didn't like you know look up to
him though but he was like on a day Me a
Genius though no for sure one of the
greats man I was I wonder too like it's
it's crazy cuz I feel like um him
passing the way he did like you know was
such a tragic situation cuz he was at
home like for you do you see [__] like
that and like make sure you're kind of
like very very careful cuz now you got a
lot of eyes on you bro yeah hell yeah on
the dad homies bro i' be like paranoid
cuz i' be already like moving a certain
way though on the dad homies I don't
like being a certain place too long I be
like in and out on like cuz I already
know [__] like that can happen I already
know and you're very recognizable I'm
very recognizable everybody already know
me your face tattoos are very I mean
people people see you know you you don't
know them they can [__] around it can be
like an innocent looking type [__] you
don't even know see you like oh that's
X4 [__] around text X4 up here you don't
even know crazy [__] like that so you're
always in and out of places yeah you got
to be in and out bro you'll die or [__]
around in up in a situation where you
got to kill a [__] now you fight life
yeah I no there like a lot of people
like you know for the most part
La if you're it feels like if you're if
you're doing what you're supposed to be
doing you're successful in any sort of
way like you just get more hate you know
what I'm saying and not even necessarily
from like who your quote unquote Ops
should be like people from where you're
from yeah hell yeah cuz everybody like
you know they want to be the one they Be
Like That Should Be Me That Should Be Me
type [__] cuz so that's how that should
be and it they always say like if uh
somebody ask you for something you can
say yes 10 times when you say no on the
11th time they take that [__] personal
and then there tell a [__] no that's
that's who you that's they going to
expose what it really is 100% have you
uh had to weed out any of those type of
people around your your Camp cuz
obviously like you said like you got you
know you you got you said ex-manager you
know so like have you had to kind of
like filter out any of your immediate
circle hell yeah on the day homies not
really be on it now on the day homie cuz
it's really like getting serious now so
I really like be antenna's high I really
be on [__] I ain't got time for those to
keep my grass cut anybody that do any
type of bunk snake Vibes get up out of
here um what's what's uh wax involvement
with your career nothing he just like
give me advice and [__] he just called
me the other day too and just told me
like you know I'm [__] high he just like
me and all that type of [__] great guy
that love whack man can always like call
him for advice and [__] yeah yeah
whack's a good guy yeah I've been on the
um wrong end of a screaming wack call
before was that right in 2000 was it
2015 yeah shout out to Wack he thought I
leaked a song a game song which I didn't
leak well [__] I'll probably react the
same way I somebody my song I was living
in Florida at time like yo what how the
[__] I got the song bro like I'm living
in Florida dog
like he was he's like I have my team of
hackers and they know that you're the
one that leaked it and I'm like bro what
what what hackers you got dog hey but
then he's got these Clubhouse detectives
you never know [__] it's crazy um man
hey which tattoo hurt the
most uh this one right here cuz I got
this [__] picked in jail cuz oh
so it was like like pick I got to sit
there and get that [__] like
little line by line yeah I got to re hit
again when I got out but the originally
that's kind of how they would be doing
that [__] in like uh the old days right
hell yeah oh so what is it what what did
they use is it a needle it's like yeah
like a little needle cuz on the D really
like a little staple a staple it's like
a staple cup but they make it as you
know in jail cuz all type of creative
smart ass peoplez You' be surprised no
no for sure I saw them do in Habachi in
jail so a [__] like staple C guar
string or whatever on the D homies and
they put it on rap it however the
[__] rap it do what they do do [__]
are they like make a get some batteries
wherever the [__] connect that up to
make that run how that run and do what
they do [__] great that sounds terrible
on gang how many of your tattoos did you
get in jail uh most of them most of them
yeah damn did was I I always you know my
cousins are all in prison and uh they
all fully tattooed and they would always
be like you know the guys who could do
tattoos in prison like they're kind of
like a hot commodity you know what I'm
saying like yeah cuz everybody be
wanting to get tatted and [__] so
everybody wants to get tatted so you
kind of like got to you know slide them
some some food or you know some bread on
the outside whatever it is you know the
T area hell yeah you going to make you
going to run it up you can run it up in
jail [__] A a lot of [__] you can run it
up off a lot of [__] in jail [__] how do
they get phones in
jail the guards
usually who knows yeah we don't we don't
we don't want to blow up the spot yeah
no I get it I get it I get it yeah I I
always wonder is the service terrible
though uh it depends on like where you
at like what jail you at like if you got
Metro PCS are you
[__] I ain't even like seen no
Metro like you get like an obamaphone in
jail you're like bro like we're in
[__] concrete walls there's no
service yeah it'd be like you know AT&T
Verizon [__] like that damn uh I've seen
you sprint before like yeah I I can only
imagine like that would be a necessity
it's like you got to figure out how to
get a phone like because otherwise you'd
be going [__] crazy or just reading
every book in the [__] [__] you got
to learn how to jail without a phone
though cuz there going to be certain
situations and certain environments
where you have you ain't got no phone
you're not supposed to have the phone
it's Contra yeah that [__] Contraband
cuz what was your longest bit it was
four years four years what were like uh
out of was that prison or County or what
was that what year was in County then
three years in prison and like depending
on where you're at like obvious I heard
I heard LA County Jail was it LA County
yeah I heard that well 6 months in AI
County then 6 months LA county and then
3 years jail I heard LA county is like
the absolute worst place to be I mean
yeah depending on the type of person you
is just like let's say me or him go in
to LA County are we [__] no you
straight I heard it's rough in there man
n you'll be straight you got to run with
the white boys though so you going to be
under a certain type of program you got
to be kind of
racist not not kind of racist cuz but
it's going to be certain type of rules
that you going to have to follow and if
you don't follow them then they going to
have to what are the rules well it's
different rules cuz so like let's say
you and I are homies right I'm in jail
but I got to run with the whites can you
and I have lunch no damn not in LA
county now we can't eat together cuz
it's for like yo that y'all got to
follow type [__] but us like we like do
what we like want to do type [__] well
there's some white boys that end up
going with the black now y'all fall
under mekin girl when when y going in
there so y going to have to do like y
fall under their program when y go in
county jail so you got to wake up at a
certain time do certain [__] you know
that's how I go that's the jail what if
I just want to hang out just be alone
you know you can just hang out be alone
right there in the day room sit right
there we can chop it up talking [__] but
I'm saying like what if I don't want to
roll with the whites what if I just want
to be alone can you be alone you can
walk in there and say you other but you
got to just make sure your whole career
go like that you got to walk in every
dorm and from your whatever you I'm
saying like obviously I'm white but if
I'm like hey guys like whatever y got
going on that's fine I just want to sit
in my C and read is that a possibility
well if you go in there and say you
other then you can do what the [__] you
want to do but what does other mean that
mean just other other race other like
Hawaiian or [__] Asian Asian you go
there say you other than [__] now you
fall under the black card now you know
now you got you got more lency to do and
there's some white boys that end up
following under the Black Card I seen
some some white boy that I thought was
white whole time he black like Muslims
all type of [__] what about there's some
there's some Mexicans too right they go
W in her black car too Jesus yeah man
listen you should never go back all
right we got to make sure you never go
back you got too much to you got too
much to lose now no yeah I'm out
trophied up cuz I'm out know cuz I
wonder too man cuz like you got to have
you on the other side cuz now you are
man don't go back cuz this the thing you
you I I heard you say that you know you
obviously you got music with with
Ralphie and you say you grew up
listening to Draco yeah you know Draco
was a guy who [__] man was such a tragic
situation to see him get you know
obviously killed the way he did um but I
just wonder like do you kind of are you
observant to the people who are still
kind of one foot in one foot out of the
street and rap game and how like you
know I feel like the only way to do this
music [__] is to make sure your your T
toes in you know what I'm saying yeah
you got to be all the way in cuz you got
to be all the way in cuz if you ain't
all the way in cuz on a day H you going
to find yourself in a situation where
you got to do some [__] or and you risk
you risk everything you risk your fre
everything you risk your freedom you
going to risk you got kids [__] your
kids seeing you your you and your kids
grow up all type of [__] your family
everybody that depending on your fans
what you just going to blow it 100% man
um what we we obviously you've talked a
lot about your street [__] but I'm I'm
curious like on a day-to-day basis what
are you into man you watch watch Netflix
or you [__] playing video games into
sports like what are you into yo we got
to stop the interview to tell you about
our folks at my bookie that's right man
it is betting season right now we got
football we got basketball NBA is
underway that boy wom Yana is looking
crazy
put all your money on him to win Rookie
of the Year all right do it at my bookie
right now go to my bookie all right when
you sign up at my bookie use the promo
code bootle use that promo code right
now and you're going to get a no
strings cash bonus that's right put your
deposit in withdraw the free cash up to
$200 right away I mean even if you don't
want to bet create an account get an
extra $200 take it out keep it moving
all right but look right now football
season is getting into the thick of it
all right I feel like the playoff
picture is going to start to really kind
of become a lot more clear soon all
right yo shout out to the Bangals
Bangles is finally getting it together
my Cardinals look like absolute dog [__]
which is what I love nonetheless you
could bet every single weekend on my
bookie this is what's up about my bookie
you can do your daily odds boost your
same game parlays and the crazy huge
prize pool contest use that promo code
right now on your first deposit so when
you sign up with a new account your very
first deposit use the promo code bootleg
this is important cuz you're going to
get up to $200 in cash when you use that
promo code bootleg claim your cash bonus
right now no strings attached deposit
withdraw quick there's so much going on
man try the my bookie money bag to grab
a potential Super Bro front runner at
Long Shot odds plus 38,000 on the Eagles
and Chiefs man is crazy you can bet
anything anytime anywhere they got the
full service casino going down slots
roulette whatever it is if you're into
it you you can gamble it you can bet it
my bookie sign up with that promo code
bootleg right now also got to give a big
shout out to the homies at my well I
already said my bookie [__] new
commercial shout out to the homies over
at Blue Chu man that's right blue Chu
everybody always ask me does blueo work
well you don't take my word for it try
it for free for a month by using that
promo code bootleg right now blueo has
the same active ingredients as Viagra
and Calis uh it's all wrapped up into a
blue chewable form delivered right to
your doorstep in discret packaging no
doctor's
appointments uh are needed all right you
don't have to go into the doctor
everything's online go to blue.com all
right sign up with that promo code
bootleg get your first month for free if
your dick ain't [__] it's time to get
a [__] again you know what I mean
you're dealing with a little erectile
dysfunction maybe a little anxiety at
work maybe you're stressed out maybe
you're just married to someone you're
tired of [__] let's be honest
sometimes you need a little extra you
know a little extra some some to get you
over to Finish Line get that blue chw
baby blue chw try the first month for
free they're going to give it to you for
free a month supply for free go to
blue.com use the promo code bootleg
right now thank me later let's get back
to the interview oh yeah I'll be playing
I'll be playing I'll be playing the game
CZ sometime fortnite C 2K fortnite's
fire yeah [__] fornite the OG zero build
though cuz I don't play the build
version though cuz I don't know how to
build you know how to build N I just
play Zero build and I go crazy on it
zero build you is only killing right
yeah just killing yeah those Builders
are weird yeah I don't know to [__]
build some [__] like experts cuz [__]
shits all the way up in the sky built
the [__] skyscraper in like two
seconds like what the [__] so when I
play fortnite I play with my kid and he
hates me cuz like he'll watch me and
I'll be [__] I'll just go to that
Treehouse it's like real high up and
I'll just chill and wait for everybody
to kill each other you know what I'm
saying and then once it's like the last
10 I'll be like okay let me go down here
you what they call a camper yes you camp
out I'm a camper that's what he calls me
I'm a Noob and a camper yeah yeah yeah I
got a we got I got a resolution for
those though what do you do you find him
yeah I'mma find the camper bomb your
[__]
Jesus he said he's going to bomb the
campers um so and you play 2K what's
your team on
2K
um it depends cuz I don't really got
like no specific team that I just like
pick I go off whoever like who I'm
playing pick you like a Laker fan yeah
I'm really like I'm really like a James
Harden fan I I was like a big Rockets
fan when Co was in the Rockets then cut
left and he heard my heart cuz I'm
really like a James Harden fan but yeah
how do you feel about Lakers are you a
Clipper fan now since Harden's there nah
cuz once once once once he uh left the
Rockets cuz I was already like you know
on the day of homies I was already
getting over and he's been a lot less
fun to watch since he left the Rockets
yeah he left the rockets and broke my
heart already already like I was getting
over him so you kind of a Rockets fan I
was when he was thereally they got a
little Squad right now who the Clippers
no the Rockets who they got they got
some young guys they got Jaylen green
they got um Jabari Smith they got Dyan
Brooks they got Fred Van Fleet I heard
heard oh yeah Fred C go crazy they got a
little Squad going over there it's
definitely they just smoked the Lakers
by all them names was cool but all them
names ain't big enough to do nothing
though they smoked the Lakers by 30 last
night but 80 was out exactly yeah I a I
haven't been watching that [__] cuz on
the D homies I ain't been watching no
Sports this season I know you're uh
tight with Deshawn Jackson you guys are
from the same Hood uh what's it like
having like a guy like djck you know
it's B on the dead homies that's he's a
legend Hall of Famer future Hall of
Famer yeah for sure future Hall of Famer
going crazy on gang that's bro dead
homies I I know he was doing the what
was the name of his label you could
probably help me was jackp jackpot I was
going to say jackpot yeah I know he was
doing that he got the jackpot [__]
rolling you ever try to sign you nah nah
he probably regrets not trying to sign
you no but he had a like you know a
legit reason on the dead homies on CP G
that made a lot of sense so on G what
was his reason well you know you know
some little inside [__] it was a legit
reason that's fair yeah yeah that's fair
legit reason for sure for sure uh you
just signed a big deal congratulations
yeah um I saw I saw uh it's gin right
yeah shout out to good talk shout my guy
Johnny shes okay um what was the bidding
war like for you though cuz it had to be
like yeah it wasn't like they're the
only people trying to sign you n yeah it
was all type of people tapping in how
many people were trying to sign you
Empire
[__] they always tapping in who from
Empire is trying to talk to you Gentry
[__] I don't remember no [__] name
just tell me I [__] got to go through
my text hey I'm with you from with you
hey I'm with you yeah so everybody
everybody was trying to get at you yeah
for sure so what made you especially
like after like I posted cuz everybody
thought I was sign a whack CU cuz I took
that picture of whack and The Wack
conversation like kept popping up but
after I posted like I'm not signing
nobody that [__] like on my yeah I think
I I I I heard like I thought that you
might have been signed with whack as
well yeah everybody thought that so
after like I posted like on my story
like I'm not signed I'm G my story like
be rolling getting gang of view so what
made you choose though Gein and good
talk those guys cuz they were just like
you know everything they touch turn to
go I mean and they just like you know
they was talking right have you heard of
that Mexican OT obviously that's your
label mate yeah he just got a gold
plaque yeah he going crazy me and uh I
went to Houston with that Mexican lot
and we went hog hunting we was murdered
H hogs out of out of a helicopter I want
to hunt out a helicopter out of a
[__] helicopter me and OT was [__]
we had the [__] r 15s that's sick and
we smoked we probably killed like 10
pigs great yeah there's a vlog coming
soon it was a good time man you should
you know what I think that people like
hunting I never was like a hunter ever
this is the first time I ever hunted but
I was like oh this is kind of like you
know if you want to get some aggression
out just go a helicopter though that's
like kind of like you know you'll think
you'll start with the simple just you
know on the ground so we did that like
you up cuz that's what you call Trophy
and up cuz you really trophied up
straight to the helicopter and then at
night we uh we did like 2 a.m. hunt
where we had like night vision goggles
on and we like stalked a bunch of pigs
and then we found them and just put them
down that [__] did y'all like go go go
go take them in and eat bacon n we just
left them there oh cuz they're pest
they're like uh they're like pest to the
area they're they're you pork do you eat
pork I love the pork okay do you hell
yeah [__] the swine is divine I'm black
[__] I eat pork [__] first of all a
lot of black people will say they don't
eat the swine no pork on my Fork I hear
that all the time I got my best friend
in the world is and he will not touch
yeah that's true but they they they
really like deep down they really like
want to do this [__] why you would Pig
it's so good and a lot of people that be
saying they don't eat pork on the dayie
they get byel and really do it up listen
you know turkey bacon ain't good that
[__] bunk run that [__] is
trash get you some real [__] bacon
come on girl the real deal some pork
chops come on some ham with the red
rooster on it imagine that's the only
hot sauce I eat too reder I can't eat no
other really hot sauce like really so
likeed straight Red Rooster and T ofo
feel solid I I like Tobasco on my eggs I
don't eat nothing else cuz like what's
that sauce that come with the Green Top
cuz D Green Top you talking about
Tabasco no no uh on a dead homie just
got uh with the Green Top cuz it's like
red it's like clear come in the clear
container that's Tabasco sauce no it's
not Tobasco it has a green lid it's like
it's tall though it's like a tall can
it's like tall it's clear the sauce is
like
red I'm G to show you on a diasco no not
Tabasco not this srra on [__] Sriracha
Sriracha you Sriracha no I don't eat
that yeah Sriracha is gas I ain't gonna
lie honestly like I can [__] with any
hot sauce I feel like as long if I open
the fridge if I'm at someone's house and
they make food and I'm like what you got
is whatever they got I'm like I got to
[__] with it yeah cuz I can't do that
bro I'm picky as [__] on the deal I
don't are you picky with everything you
eat hell yeah like will you eat oysters
yeah so you okay well you're not that
picky that's jail that's jail food
though bro they sell oysters on the jail
list well I mean listen I always if
someone says they eat oysters they can't
be that picky cuz the real picky
[__] oysters that you put that
in a sprad on the day I'm us do it up o
good so what is like something most
people eat that you won't [__] with uh
that most people it's a lot of [__] that
most people eat I don't eat tacos what
the [__] well it's really like the it's
the corn shell I don't eat the shell but
you do a flour I don't yeah I do a
flower shell you don't like corn
tortillas no I don't eat pickles onions
ketchup mustard mayonnaise my Burgers
just like like got meat and cheese on it
that's it yeah I'm like a simple eater
cuz you're like my kid [__] 10 I I
eat simple cuz we go to the drivethru
and it's like cheeseburger plain yeah
plain cheeseburger so no ketchup no
onions no pickles no mayonnaise no
mustard none of that [__] just like
might throw some bacon on there cuz how
do you eat a hot dog just
straight uh put some uh put some pork
and beans on it on D you put some pork
and beans on it some cheese on [__] and
crunch some hot chips on it okay and do
it do it up like that but no sauce no
sauce you're not a guy unless it's red
rooster yeah unless it's red rooster but
that don't go on a hot dog no no no no
doesn't I mean it could go you never
know you do that [__] on the D you nasty
hey you're going to have a rough day at
the uh the restroom for sure yeah damn
no tacos and you are from La yeah [__]
the taco trucks are amazing we have the
best taco trucks in the country here
yeah yeah but you eat a flower Taco we
eat a flower one or you eat a burrito
yeah I eat a burrito cuz with just like
meat and cheese and that [__] and rice
you like store the stuff they shave off
with the with the pineapple on the top
no I don't get that just do assada yeah
either assada or like sometimes chicken
or I might feeling fancy cuz I might mix
you might do both might do both give me
both give me the steak you you [__] with
like seafood though
right um if it's like fried like fried
shrimp and like Cafe but you don't have
like a cold shrimp cocktail n hell no
damn it's got to be like a certain way
it's got to be deep fried yeah okay I
respect that they have Oysters in jail
hell yeah oysters macro wait how the
[__] do the oysters come in jail are
they in a
can not in a [__] can they come like
in a [__] uh they can come in a they
some prisons like they serve them
different some come in a pouch and some
come in low can [__] too some I would
not want jail oysters no it's like the
regular oysters from the street like you
go in a grocery store that same brand in
prison bro I like oysters on a half
shell on ice and then you slurp it oh
like like the real oyster yeah I'm
talking about like oysters bro at the
grocery store bro I never had those
trench [__] [__] bro like I see that
grocery store oysters grocery store
oysters with the noodles you [__] with
sardines sardines that's like the fish
in the can sardines oh yeah oh yeah yeah
not like that though cuz but I had them
in the spread before a couple times on
the day homies if you were to concoct
the go-to spread what is it in your
spread okay first you got to get
uh noodles okay pack of noodles pack of
noodles cuz refi beans cuz not the ones
not the refi beans you think though the
ones that come in jail the dry refi
beans in the back okay yeah yeah yeah
homies throw those in there de homies
sausage cuz chop some sausage up in
there crib what kind of sauses like
Vienna like the little weeds that come
in the can no it's Hometown all these
[__] I'm talking about is jail Brands
it's like it's called Hometown Hometown
sausage it's called Hometown sausage cuz
bam chop CS up in there Bop on a DE
homies uh throw some [__] pork rinds
in there H squeeze some hot hot
Barbecues in there uh on [__] I'm
following you yeah hell yeah on the dead
homies see on the Dead Homie you can get
some little you can get some cheese in a
c put some cheese in that issue on the
dead homies put the water in there car
then you then you fry it or you you just
no you put the water in there Bop Let it
do what it do when it sit right there
and there then you get all your little
side ingredients cuz cheesy cheese
that's how you make that cuz the cheese
you make it out of cheit it sounds good
CP jelly on the put the jelly on top
wait you're putting jelly on this jelly
cheese sprinkle some more chips cut
crunched up chips is there a dessert
version of the spread that you would do
a deserve version yeah I don't I don't
know how to do that CU there all type of
[__] make all type of [__] in there
have you ever seen the I saw on video uh
they were doing
Habachi where it was like almost like
Benny Han's been in jail they was like
they had like the yeah it's fries and
there all type of [__] that shit's crazy
yeah hell yeah it's fries and that
[__] but it's like they like
they were using like the bed frame I
think it's like like what they were
heating up got to get creative in that
[__] Jesus throw you in there
you got to survive and then the alcohol
what do they just they almost like make
wine right yeah jeez shout out to the
man I will say that man you end up in
jail [__] got to get creative
got to get creative cuz you got to
survive I feel like if people applied
that same like you know thought process
when they get out to like some legal
[__] it' be lit [__] some [__] do bro
some [__] got that [__] rich
as a [__] some [__] get out get
killed it just depends on who the [__]
you is do think you see what I got out
and did I'm right here with you 100% I
was going to say what do you think the
main like um cuz you know you like you
said there's people who get out and then
they it's almost like a rotating door
they just keep kind of going back in
keep getting locked up do you think
that's a mentality thing do you think
it's cuz they end up getting out kicking
it with the same folks they were kicking
with before like what is what do you
think can break the cycle for somebody
like that break the cycle for them like
get on and do different yeah just cuz
they keep coming like like like like
there's like you know predicate
criminals who just end up in jail no
matter what like my cousin's like one of
them he's been in jail since he was 18
and he's I was I was one of those
growing up bro I used to always be in
jail cuz cuz like just the crowd
environment just the [__] that you do
what changed for you got tired of being
in that [__] CU and you know
and just having a talent know all a rap
cuz like I feel like you know you hear
about like being in like
uh with the solitary confinement like
that shit's got to be tough yeah hell
yeah I was just in a dungeon cut the
last time I went I was in the county I
was in a dungeon cut for like eight days
what's the dungeon Sol it's like the
hole inside the hole the whole inside
the hole Yeah so how many hours a day
you 23 [__] [__] 24 you never come
out that [__] really de homies
that feels like it should be then you
come out every other day cut a shower
for about like 5 minutes on the dam
right back I'm cing that [__] 8
days how long did that 8 Days 8 Days
feel though like a year oh man then you
probably like that [__] like [__] with
your mental on the dead homies they
wonder why talk about C crazy c not
crazy on the dead homies C just been
through some [__] on that's what I'm
saying like I feel like if you're in
like a place like that like your
thoughts just take your brain over
that's all you got to there is your
thoughts so if you're like a weak-minded
person though you'll [__] around slice
your wrist you'll [__] around on a de
homies a crazy person ain't go be in the
type of situation without him being in
and you know on the de homies and still
come out trophied up big dog status like
this a lot of people situations and [__]
I been through and been in a lot of
people could have been folded on game a
lot of people would have been folded no
that's real like you like like I think
like if you're a weak-minded person you
should try to follow the law cuz
otherwise you're going to be [__] up
in jail yeah you're going to be [__]
up for sure um what are you working on
right now you working on the the the
debut album or what's what's going on
working on some little [__] I'm working
on tape you been putting out a lot of
music videos yeah on gang I've been
putting out some [__] I've been
recording a lot though I got a lot of
little songs put up in the safe ready
are you uh are you the type of guy who
writes stuff down or you going in and no
I just go in there and just do my [__]
go there and punch in cuz yeah hell yeah
go in there punch in made some [__] last
night cuz I'm crazy punched it in fire
hell yeah what is uh well like how do
you distinguish what's going to go in a
project and what's going to you know
maybe be a single to just throw out and
see what happens well you listen to that
[__] cuz you'll know cuz once you
listening to that [__] you'll be like
all right bam if you make like five
songs and you listen to those
[__] you can be able to pick
out which one is the best one mhm on
game then make another whatever couple
more songs and then just keep comparing
them all right bam this one all right
bam this one this one hey we got to tell
you about our new partners shout out to
Imperial extraction uh this is what's
dope about Imperial extraction man we
all love free stuff right we love free
stuff do we love free weed of course we
love free weed and this is what Imperial
extraction is doing right now
this is amazing all right they got the
top shelf good [__] that zah that next
level them hitters all right and right
now they're going to be throwing in a
free 2 G thca Diamond infused pre-roll
now that's what it looks like will come
just like that this right here is the
GMO Cookies By the way I love me some
cookies all right and look at these
things man it's like a baby's it's like
a three-year-old's finger right there
you know what I'm saying no that's like
a 5-year-old's finger that's a [__]
serious boy two grams all right they got
three different strings of course they
got the GMO cookies they got the la king
Kush and they got the cereal milk and
it's free infused with the flour that's
premium and the Diamonds I'm telling you
we just busted one of these things open
it's just diamonds inside it's it's
amazing all right so this is what you
got to do uh first of all you got to
head over to Imperial extraction. comom
use the code bootleg right now Imperial
extraction. comom use that code bootleg
and you will get your free 2 G pre-roll
today you're also going to see the QR
code so make sure you click on that QR
code also while you're at the website
man you're going to get hooked up with
all the merch if you need some like
discounts on the merch whatever use that
promo code you see the uh you see the
hoodie that hoodie is flying this is
some real quality right here some real
real quality all right so make sure you
go over there they got so much goodness
going on man look they got the Vape
pods and let me tell you the watermelon
sherbet that's my favorite they got the
STW Strawberry Pound Cake you can go
over there get you your battery your
battery is uh essential this is some
high quality [__] right here you of
course you get your pod get your
battery you do this with the this with
the this you get one of these for free
all by using the promo code bootleg
right now Imperial extraction. comom
that's Imperial extraction. comom go to
the website use that promo code or just
hit that QR code with your phone haha
bra shout out to Imperial extraction all
Hi man also want to give a shout out to
our family over at King pom baby you
already know man we always stay King
pomed up over here it's the only thing
we're smoking you know what I love about
King pom so many
flavors so natural organic tobacco free
leaves this is how we're smoking at the
bootleg Kev podcast and um like let me
just say this dude like all shapes and
sizes you know what I mean like it's
give you a little variation of the type
of King Pals you can get down with you
know just different shapes different
sizes
natural organic tobacco free a clean
smoke if you will so many this this is
the honey berry which might be my new
favorite I do love the uh the energy
drink one the red rain is fire all right
um but listen if you want to get down
with some of these King Pals trust me
when I say man they are the best way to
smoke um first of all you can go to your
local liquor store 7-Eleven all that
they got King poms all right so go pick
something up or you can go to their
website now if you go to their website
King pom.com go to King pom.com use the
promo code bootleg right now and uh you
can say 50% off at King pom.com half off
whatever you want what are we
smoking this is the uh the Orange Swirl
what's dope about King pom is they have
like the flavor the tarpine infused tips
so like let's say you got this one right
you got some of that Orange Swirl you
feel
me you load it up put your wheat in
there
or whatever your
tobacco and then in the tip you press
down on that thing and you're getting
hit with all that
flavor all right so go to uh King
pom.com use the promo code bootleg right
now get half off or just go to your
local liquor store go to your local
7-Eleven and run it up with some King
Pals also want to give a shout out to
our family at odd Sox man don't forget
get you some odd Soxs in your life go to
oddsocks official.com right now holiday
season's coming they make great gifts
man we can do so much they got the ET
you I mean they got the draws if you
already know odd Soxs making underwear
now and they're more comfortable than
all the other underwear Brands let me be
honest with you all right they got all
the licenses how about Top Ramen
underwear let me just take a peek of
these bad
boys see what we got here the ramen
draws baby what how about some Mountain
Dew Code Red Socks or or you know what
how about this how about we we keep the
soda theme going we got Mountain Dew box
blast oh wait wait wait wait wait we we
we don't want either of those we'll keep
the soda them going what about some
orange crush socks what if you're fat
like me you like chocolate Hershey's
they got WWE Breaking Bad Godfather good
I mean just all of the damn things Power
Rangers all the crazy licenses go to
oddsock official.com use the promo code
bootleg right now and you will save 20%
off oddsock official.com promo code
bootleg save 20% off your total order
right now let's get back to the
interviews has any of the um La OG
producers tapped in with you yet y all
type of producers be tapping in C but
like I don't really be I've been like
feeling that Bez lately like do you do
you have like your in-house guys you
[__] with yeah just thatb I'll be like
[__] on that be yeah be right there like
has mustard hit you at all n must didn't
hit me there's so many I mean I just
feel like LA's got so many just prolific
producers that are just incredible man
no yeah it's a gang yeah it's a gang of
like producers cuz they me all type of
producers cuz big buo so of produc for
sure would you uh would you work with
blueface cuz you and uh you obviously
you and you know wax wax a big homie and
blueface is a genius lowy I always tell
everybody he's somehow mastered the
internet in a way that I feel like you
always like you always scrolling and and
see you going to see he's just like you
know like some people understand how to
go viral and understand the internet
like on a high level he's like the the
internet genius like this man put both
his baby mamas on like the the his OG
baby mama [__] just signed a real
record deal with Colombia like this [__]
is crazy like yeah shout out to blue man
yo I wonder you went viral a couple of
weeks ago you went on no jumper MH and
uh Adam asked you what he asked you and
then you just stayed silent yeah which I
feel like should be uh applied more if
you're an artist Who's involved in
certain Lifestyles I feel like most
people just need to shut the [__] up
yeah man a lot of the people could get
on this camera and be trying to make
their s look good tell a story yeah
walked in there po him up to him up Cho
him up do all type of weak ass gay ass
[__] on camera D me now they be in jail
D you in jail yeah well like young thug
they just came out today they're
actually the trial just started and
they're going to use his lyrics against
them so let alone interviews but for you
like going viral uh with that do you
feel like Adam was trying to like you
know a lot of people say Adam's the
[__] uh what do they call him the
feds no could not the feds bro no Adam's
a great guy he's my boy but I just want
like like I you know I always tell
people like uh when they go on Vlad or
when they go on no jumper like yo you
it's up to you how you answer I need
stop calling C F too cuz my boy invited
me to his birthday party too cuz I'mma
see you there yeah what's it next week
right popping up you're pulling up yeah
Jesus Christ pull up the only thing I'm
wor see when when like [__] like that
like cuz Adams like knows so many gang
members yeah I'm like there's going to
be a lot of people already to bro I'm to
[__] no Ops [__] them are me okay and
he P you okay okay so trophy cuz trophy
status trophy no Ops will be in the
building hell no that's that's a great
yeah yeah that's the one thing with like
I got I'm going to Adam's birthday party
too so I'll see you there we she have a
good time but it's funny that that clip
went so viral cuz like you literally
just stayed I thought the [__] video
they used to so many rappers just
getting on there and just talking so
much when somebody do some different
[__] it's like oh wow on game yeah but
that's just hobby that's what you that's
what you just talk growing up don't say
[__] bro don't care yourself don't
that's just normal was on Vlad PeeWee
Longway was on Vlad I don't know if you
ever see that clip he was asking about
being a [__] and pee Longway just looked
at he was just like it's crazy um for
you man like uh talk about like is there
anything that you have noticed you know
since signing your deal since I guess
you've had so much momentum over the
last four or five months but is there
anything that you've noticed and or
learned um about the music game cuz the
music game and the street [__] is
totally different the music business is
the music business it is the music
business key word is business yeah on
the dad that's what I really learned
like everything really like business
it's not just hit a [__] up hey see me
be record it bam drop it just all right
bam it's like way [__] agreement on the
it's like steps to this [__] right you
got to get people's publishing
information yeah yeah it's really like
it's really like steps to this [__] so
it's bigger than just like getting a
beats in and just recording it he
shooting a video and dropping it's like
really like real [__] actual label so
everything you do got to have some sort
of paperwork everything is like
paperwork involved and all that type of
[__] so yeah well some artists will take
that [__] personal cuz they be like wait
a minute we just hanging out the studio
why I got to like yeah like no like this
is just how it goes and it's funny cuz
on the D homies on the D homies couple
people hit me up too that was like M bro
like this what's going on all right
nobody didn't feel like nobody didn't
get bed about it though they can't C you
know know [__] people get B hurt though
yeah that's that because because they
[__] that's fair anybody uh feature
wise that you're sitting on right now
that you've been working
with yeah I got a I got I got a crazy
feature coming cuz it's crazy though is
it already done yeah who is it you going
to see cuz where they
from LA County LA County that's a that's
a very general they booming they're
booming from LA County top top rank top
rank of course top rank blast no Ry
[__]
no even if do say the name I'm not going
to say
it I mean hey hey you to rank though
this going to be the one you and blast
would be crazy get blast on a hook
that's [__] out of here yeah blast do
got some fire hooks though blast go
crazy I saw you love R Rodriguez yeah R
go crazy peace hard I I uhra we had a a
very entertaining fun interview here you
entertaining I mean you interviewed him
yeah it was great we actually had fun
like he was actually like you know you
know like he you could tell he's not
comfortable being on camera like yeah
he's just like a normal dude who's
famous you know what I'm saying so we
talked about all kind of wild [__] but I
wonder like for you like who who would
you consider to be your biggest
influences on your sound like when I'm
listening to you like who influenced
your sound musically nobody cuz like
myself I really like got my own sound
cuz I go in there and do my own [__]
punch in my own way I influence my own
sound yeah yeah I do my own [__] yeah so
you feel like I mean obviously you were
listening to Draco though were you
listening to any of the shoreline [__]
yeah but should I yeah uh yeah I was
listening to them too growing up on
games shout Oz yeah Oz and them was
going crazy [__] yeah I was listening to
a lot of people growing up cuz just at
that moment like Draco was like the
first one that popped in my head so they
like really like took that and R with it
oh he was listening to Draco oh and
Draco influence n you know wasn't like
my influence it was hard though I listen
to a lot of people growing up but Draco
was just like one of the main like that
whole W like greo Shoreline drao Draco
like all them on Mike Sher was like
booming around that shout out to Mike sh
asshol is a classic G shout out to the
Bay yeah on the dead homies but like
yeah I was listening to them but like
yeah nobody really like influenc my
sound they ain't heard nobody rapping be
like Oh I'm going to start rapping like
this or I want to just do this what like
um do you remember like when did you
first record your first record like when
you when's the first time you like laid
some vocals in Pro Tools or uh 2016 okay
so you've been like you been kind of
when did you would you say you you
finally took this [__] serious once you
got out yeah I took it serious when I
got out like 20 like last year last year
yeah my oldest video my oldest video on
YouTube only say 11 months ago that's
crazy so that was like like I'm barely
like fresh bro I'm barely like on a
homies bro and so did you have the plan
together like
yo I'm getting out and I'm doing this
[__] for real yeah hell yeah hell yeah
and then when I get out when I got out
and then did the [__] with rimo seen the
reaction in the backlash that I'm like
okay yeah shout out to ramble man he's a
word Smith yeah shout out ramble go
crazy he's [__] hard bro he be having
the most illest like I love his delivery
but his punch lines like his lines be so
[__] crazy
like listen to some you going to laugh
about three
times she be like yo talking crazy why
didn't I think of that like that was he
said the most basic like relatable [__]
in the flyest way yeah yeah shout out to
ramble yeah for sure we need a rmo album
bro it's been a minute yeah that song he
got with blast uh was it child of God
that shit's hard as [__] that [__] hard
uh is raino going to be on your
album
probably probably probably probably I
like that I like that so ramble and then
another bigger LA County yeah you got to
get with [__] that Mexican OT you
guys are label mates yeah probably he's
um he's a superstar man he's he's on his
way have you heard his [__] I heard like
a song or two yeah he's hard and you
guys need to go hog hunting in Texas
yeah yeah yeah it's a lot of [__] cuz
that I'll be interested doing cuz a lot
of people won't even think that I do
like what like [__] bungee jumping
cuz I want to do that [__] I want to
[__] Skydive yeah see that's all type
of I draw the line on skydiving I feel
like if I'm going to jump out of a plan
Will Smith be making all that [__] look
cool cuz Will Smith does make skydiving
look amazing C make everything look
amazing Volcan and [__] except being
with j p Smith that does not look
amazing yeah C bunk for that but I'm
talking about like like travel life oh
he's doing all the cool adventure [__]
travel life C make everything look fun
you be like what the [__] I would to go
right here oh yeah his IG is wild but
yeah that yeah she she she bunk run cuz
de homie she bunk yeah yeah she's just
out here doing [__] interviews doing
she getting hit she she try she getting
the August alcena on the side yes shout
out to Jada a very stressful
relationship I'm sure to be a part of
shout out to Will Smith who's a better
man than I am I'll say that yeah uh
skydiving I feel like if I were to
skydive you'd have to pay me to jump out
of a plane [__] it look like paying you
to jump out the
plane I'mma pay you so I can jump out of
a plane you going to pay them for the
experience nah n you got to pay me and
you can be able to not too many people
can walk around and be able to say like
yeah I jumped out a plane cuz you got to
go do that like yeah I did that we
should go we should go do it we get
someone to give it to us for free we'll
do a vlog on dead homies skydiving with
X4 on CRI that should have go viral that
should have go viral dead homies I'm
going be spooked oh man get the GoPros
yeah it go crazy I'm in I don't know
about bungee jumping bung for some
reason bungee jumping feels a little
more sketchy you feel like the little
core bungee jumping more Sketcher than
skydiving I feel like the core in my
snap if you bungee jump like words it's
like water though you'll be spoty that's
fair but if you Skydive it ain't no you
you dead if the if the parachutes are
rap it's over it's over way for you I'm
ready I'm ready to take a risk that's
fair that's fair yeah you I mean we
probably each done some riskier [__]
than then uh hell yeah man [__] do
riskier [__] than that [__] we died in
some [__] with no kind of I want the
d you took the birds right in my mouth
for sure you know what I'm saying damn
oh G 100% uh that's dope man have you
made your way up to the Bay at all yet
uh let me see what's some Bay artist I
San Francisco Oakland then there's like
obviously with Northern California
there's uh sack uh shout out to mazi's
doing his thing as sack obviously
Stockton's going crazy right now yeah I
ain't tapped in with none of them [__]
yet I don't know I got all type of DMS
some of them probably T Yo Stockton got
like one of the like hardest like
hip-hop scenes in Cali right now oh yeah
yeah they got they got a dope just a
dope wave coming out of Stockton yeah
that's where that's where uh the boy and
all them from the boy's from Oakland or
he's from
Vallejo that way in the bay but the boy
hard yeah yeah yeah you got I feel like
y'all would go crazy if y'all work
together yeah yeah he's a he's another
one of them guys who just got some
[__] who's what about anybody from
Detroit you should work with cash kid
bro uh oh I'm uh oh I just had of that
ice for vzo vzo is hard as [__] did he
tap back in yeah yeah I talked I was on
FaceTime yeah he's hard he's a great
dude too man he a real like he's also
somebody who did some like he did some
real real prison time and came out on
the other side of it better for it you
know what I'm saying and he's doing a
ton of like just boss [__] bro this
[__] we went to Detroit hung out
with him and he had went to the liquor
store they had his chips in there they
had his Vape in there he got all kind of
businesses vos's he's doing movies and
[__] yeah going so would you ever act I
feel like I feel like I can be I feel
like I can play some movies
well you know they're going to you're
just going to play the they're going to
typ cast you I feel like yeah I feel I
got the image cut of being like in a
movie but I can't play I can't play no
bunk ass Ro though cuz I got whatever
movie I got to be in I got to be like
the top [__] cuz I want to be the [__]
on [__] gang sitting right there cut the
desk cuz on [__] telling [__] on the go
open the door cuz you count this money
cuz you give me my water on the day
homies you a [__] shut up on the day
homies you come here I do this D homies
[__] gang her you get the [__] out you
ugly D I want to be running [__] well
you kind of have to play yourself or a a
gang I mean unless they're going to put
makeup on your face
no they ain't doing doing none of that
hey man they might if you let's say you
get a rooll and they they want you to be
a high school kid or something n cuz I
just told you the type of Ro I'm be in
I'm tell see I'm giving instructions cuz
I'm ordering [__] like the boss be like
on some boss [__] cuz just put to play
yourself [__] walking around naked
cuz in the house I'm just like on the D
making important calls on doing like
important [__] all my scenes is just
important [__] they going to be like oh
cut the [__] in the movie you be like
[__] the guy in snowfall that uh
what's what's what's uh snow yeah there
you go shout out to did you watch
snowfall I said snoop snoop I said Snoop
like that mean who oh I'm talking about
Franklin Saint oh Franklin yeah on gang
Franklin a big dog Co was a big do but
Co did some Buster [__] though Co was
like he had to get turned into a big dog
though like the yeah he cut this a bit
[__] so I don't want to be cut bro cuz
iut I don't want to be that type of Ro I
want to be a [__] room for no errors
did you watch did you watch all snowfall
I seen uh all the way to like season 4
yeah I watched [__] in jail oh you did
yeah Netflix on the phone no they just
had it on the TV no I had my you know I
had my waist I've seen that [__] Four
Seasons what else did you watch any
other shows you binge watched uh
Breaking Bad No I try to watch a little
bit of the shy how was that I never got
into the Shai it was 40 I only seen like
a couple episodes though CU I couldn't
really like get into it you got to I
tried to watch P Valley but that [__]
wasn't spoty bro I'm D me P Valley is
the strip club right yeah
yeah so I'm like the dead homies bro on
Hood so I watched like episode like a
couple minutes of that see now I'm like
I'm out of here is it cuz you didn't
like it because it
was yeah cuz cuz cuz like kept throwing
me off cuz on the dead homies going off
for sure yeah on F CU kept throwing me
off I'm like on the D but everybody kept
saying like this [__] hard watch it I'm
like I'm spy on the D how much of like
the like cuz for people who have no idea
about
prison we all think mother [__]
drop the soap and get [__] in the ass
that's because that's how that's how
movies that's how the movies are that's
how TV is that's how movies made it bro
on and I'm sure that there's some of
that going on no none no not just a
[__] dropping the soap and just getting
[__] it's some [__] that's probably
[__] in their sale Cs on the dead
homies but that's on them but but
there's some gay [__] going on for sure
behind closed doors [__] but unless
unless you like want to if you want like
a bunk ass prison yard it's for sure
it's like gay [__] walking around and
[__] that's boy once you want like a
real prison yard level three level four
where it's real structure real prison
you do some gay [__] you going to die
you're going to die hell yeah what the
[__] but you you like one of them bunk
ass like a bunk ass prison that's where
like it is gay [__] going on there
homies yeah but on one of them the bunk
prisons cuz and 5050 yards and [__] like
that but like real prisons hell no you
going to [__] die did you see uh kaai
sonat you know who kaat is yeah did you
see he did a he was getting some
backlash some negative backlash cuz he
did a 7-Day fake jail stream did you see
this yeah I like little clips and [__]
on Instagram what you think of that
being somebody who's actually been there
and and you know a lot of people were
saying that he should have glorified
jail I mean that thought came to my mind
but then it left instantly cuz cuz I'm
like on the day homies CU making his bag
bro CU getting his money everybody
talking about it so I'm like Oh and it
was I mean look it was funny he was kind
of just creating like a little [__]
fake reality show on the day homies at
first I'm like on the day that [__] left
quick as [__] I'm like C making his bag
bro do what he doing he it up and it was
and and he you know he had like like
Tiana Trump going always have something
to say cuz that [__] was booming C [__] d
Everybody Was there that [__] was like
that [__] was like I feel like that
seemed like that sh was like a Vibe
too saying like every time I be like oh
[__] drw's in there today oh [__] Anie
choer in there today they got TI Trump
the porn chick is the guard like yeah
it's a same thing as [__] shooting
videos cuz like you get like peer spaces
with the jail sales scenes and all that
[__] happens all the time yeah I just I
shot a video with the jail Sal scen so
it's like
what yeah they got some dope peer space
jail yeah so what on the dam like the
same yeah for sure for sure well listen
man uh hopefully we get do you have any
idea when you're going to drop a body of
work or is it just going to be singles
it's going to be no it's going to be uh
probably like a couple singles cut then
I probably bam get a little EP cut
before before before the year end yeah
on G so ep's coming before the end of
the year yeah little EP coming probably
before the end of this year cuz on game
me and FB on gang me EP um [__] a got no
name for it's going to be like something
cuz something with some trophy in it cuz
since since you've uh linked with Johnny
shes yeah he's a very funny guy yeah
kind of funny he is a hilarious man yeah
has he given you uh any sort of game
yeah give me all type of game cuz he's a
very smart guy he's obviously you know
he he's one of the first guys to ever
discover nipy hustle big crit Joey
Badass go on and on and on yeah um what
is some of the stuff that you've in such
a short time been able to learn from
shes all type of [__] cuz but one of the
main things cuz that really keep me
going why always tell me stay out of
jail cuz make you rich stay out of jail
stay out of jail make you rich Girlz you
ain't got to tell me twice stay out of
jail man I'm be a rich man long as I
stay out of jail yeah you got to stay
out of jail brother stay out of jail
stay alive man stay out the way bro yeah
for sure have you considered like
relocating to like a less active area or
have you already done that well yeah
yeah hell yeah but not too too far away
from La like you know you want to be
ducked off but not too too far cuz you
got to be ducked off though yeah you got
to be ducked off cuz like you know you
got to be ducked off you know too far
though cuz like 30 40 minutes away it be
cool right well you know once you start
becoming like a millionaire yeah well
once you can start coming a millionaire
then on the day homies on [__] I'm not
going to go out of state though but I'm
just going to like I'll say you might be
able to go to Vegas nah hell no I ain't
go to Vegas I'll probably still be
somewhere IA be like Hollywood Hills
Calabasas somewhere or some Calabasas is
the V yeah for sure there it is man look
I appreciate you pulling up X4 much love
to you brother uh make sure you go
support he got tons of Music out tons of
Music out more music coming pop it all
type of [__] congratulations on uh the
deal look forward to seeing you blow up
man keep doing your thing brother go CRA
fire trophy game boom yo we're wrapping
up an interview man of course we want to
shout out to our family at harden baby
Harden Las Vegas celebrating their
seventh birthday this month so happy
birthday to harden uh want to give a
shout out to the whole family over there
when you're in Las Vegas you got to pull
up to harden tell them that the bootleg
C podcast send you they're going to take
care of you it is the craziest selection
of Premium cannabis in the country all
Under One Roof you walk in and it's just
a Vibe beautiful Bud tenders amazing
smoke just the illst merch you know what
I'm saying and it's right in Las Vegas
right in s City so you land in Vegas you
about to go gamble with your boys you
get in that cab you say take me to
hardine they're going to know exactly
where to take you all right shout out to
harden go follow him Hardin Las Vegas or
go to the website Hardin vegas.com